[Music]
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
look around the world who do you see
a planet from the brink of collapse
human gains are disposable but man and
symbiote a mind this is the new race
your species the higher life-form
we cannot just hurt people
[Music]
Bedelia so many tracks on people time
that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
today Oh operator
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
going down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah name is Jan
I've always believed huh space
exploration is crucial in our quest to
cure everything veils us here on earth
so that's how does that work you know
exactly the light foundation thing how
does it how does it how does it go about
say testing pharmaceuticals Eddie what's
talking about the rocket you know I'm
not I'm not I'm talking about the
allegations it says that you recruit the
most vulnerable of us to volunteer for
tests and that more often than not end
up killing people thank you very much
we're not finished yes you are mr. Brock
is that a threat have a nice life the
hell is this guy I'm gonna need mr.
Drake's property back Oh what are you
doing take him down
Stucky now let's fight all the heads off
I think the most exciting thing about
this film is having the opportunity to
take a truly beloved character from
comic books
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter and
combine that with one of the most
exciting actors in the world Tom Hardy I
have been it's about a man who's doing
with a shadow side you have no idea how
much you're scaring me right now we're
incredibly lucky to have Tom play Eddie
Brock we cannot just hurt people and
venom
there's this Jekyll and Hyde duality
[Music]
[Applause]
it's edgy and gritty and dark so ladies
a little time
which i think is just so much more
interesting and complex and a typical
superhero that power it's not completely
awful are you gonna behave yourself
tomorrow no I'm gonna do my job that's
what I'm gonna do I can't you know an
act do my job but we don't want to
repeat repeat after Danny clue incident
Wow
really maybe you were run out of New
York I when she went out of San
Francisco no I still have currency in
New York I was going places I wasn't
running I was going places I moved to
San Francisco for you you are my home
nice about yourself Jim you do not want
to do this trust me ah
haven't you away
thank you for bringing us collectively
to this moment it is a moment that so
many have dreamed of claiming history
starts today
[Music]
the guy you were for is the evil person
I don't work for him
my firm works for me are you gonna
behave yourself tomorrow I totally
wanted my job I'm a reporter I follow
people that do not want to be followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people do timeso
finish mr. boss is that a threat you had
to learn how to hide in plain sight I'm
pretty good at it but you you suck
whoever you are I work at the Life
Foundation and I need your help
we found something we call them
symbiosis Carleton Drake believes that
the union between human and symbiote is
the key to our evolution
I'm feeling really sick
I'm here boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
[Music]
why would we do this
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people when I see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
you willing to sacrifice
thing you hold most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
unfit
[Music]
everyone's got this thing
[Music]
maybe it's a breakup a death an accident
whatever it is you used to be one thing
now
you're something else
[Music]
we all have our own problems
our own issues
demons
[Music]